I have knee pain since December. I use DMSL cream and drops with red light therapy which helped
also rye frequency. Is there a supplement for joint and inflammation for this issue?
I can also be, can it also be caused from detoxing? Well, I wouldn't, if you're asking if
knee pain can be caused from detoxing, I would say, yeah, probably not. Is there a supplement
for joint and inflammation? So your larger joints like your knee joint and your hip joint
are fluid fill joints. I mean, most of your joints are fluid fill joints, but they're going to produce
a fluid in that joint capsule. So there's a capsule three dimensionally around these two bones
that are coming together to form a joint. And in that capsule is a fluid that is that is joint
fluid and it's produced by the capsule cells. And as we age, that joint fluid decreases and we
that's where our bones can rub a little bit more, be irritated when we're walking a lot or
weight bearing, especially our bigger weight bearing joints. So what can help us produce more of that
joint fluid because it is the joint fluid and then gas within the fluid that gives it a push.
You got millions of little bubbles within that inside that joint fluid that give the cushion
of that joint to protect the two bones rubbing together. So there's two things called glucosamine
and condroitin that can increase joint fluid production. How it doesn't really help with your
finger joints as much, but it helps with your larger joints, especially the knees, it can be really
helpful. So taking glucosamine and condroitin and neither of them are contraindicative for cancer patients,
that can help increase joint fluid production and millions of people have taken that to help with
degenerative arthritis, which is that loss of joint fluid and some sparing of the bones. So
condroitin and glucosamine, you can usually get them in products that have both of them in a product
that has both of those in there.